hey man it's me kevin smith we're gonna
do a little scene study on mall rats my
second movie man and we are going to
look at the blueprints sequence
now naturally i will agree a great debt
of gratitude
to the good folks at warner brothers
particularly chuck jones for
all the wiley coyote and and roadrunner
shorts uh because that's essentially
all this stuff is um it's uh blueprints
just like wiley coyote would make and
from acme and stuff
and uh we're trying to get something
accomplished
so i'll i'll never forget scott mosher
drew the blueprints and they were
actually like blueprints
and um when we did the first cut of the
movie
um we showed the blueprints like we did
but there was no j voiceover
and so it was just like hauntingly quiet
so in further uh
the edits of the flick that was when i
brought jay in and wrote lines for him
say this line
first first you take a run at the fours
with a sock full of quarters i'd do it
but i pulled
my back out humping your mom last night
huge so all that was like written
while we were in the adr uh stage in
post
on mall rats one of the last things
added to the movie and stuff and yet
his voiceover just makes it absolutely
uh what it is
i get to swing around and skate around
and [ __ ] like that
um you know this it's this is the slap
sticky [ __ ]
that jay's character complains about in
chasing amy
when he's just like why you got me
saying stoogey boo she's running around
all slap sticky and [ __ ]
um that's that's jane samba they they
didn't want me to lean on the drugs so
much
like i was like they're weed dealers
like well see save that for the third
act and [ __ ] like that but
so they had to get up to mischief and so
here they are
trying to take down the stage it's uh me
as uh simon bob jason muse uh as the
immortal j
and uh and and of course um sven ollie
thorson
as lefour's a character that i borrowed
from
butch cassidy and the sundance kid have
you ever seen butch cassidy and the
sundance kid
uh throughout the second half of the
movie they're terrified because they're
being chased by joe lefors
and you know at the end they're like uh
it's stuck in the house in bolivia where
they're about to get blown away by the
entire bolivian army
and they look out the window and he's
like hey do you see the fours out there
and he goes no and he goes for a minute
i thought we were in trouble you know
and then they get out and [ __ ] get
gunned down by hundreds of people so
lefour's in
in the movie they've referenced him as
wearing a straw boater in
in uh butch cassie and sundance kid that
is why our lefors
wears that ridiculous hat through the
whole [ __ ] movie and stuff so just a
little little inside info man for some
[ __ ] that happened
literally 26 [ __ ] years ago
holy [ __ ] uh boy do i got a memory and
they say i'm a stoner
uh regardless take a look at uh this
sequence from all rats the
blueprint scenes okay lunchbox let's try
this again
we tidy the roof and you jump off and
sound like a spitfire passing right over
the arch nemesis the fours
you then swing up to the stage and knock
out the pin and when that's gone the
stage is trashed and we go smoke a bowl
you got it now get your fat ass up there
and dude
don't forget your helmet snoogins
[Music]
my fattest lives
[Music]
what the [ __ ] you [ __ ]
hey kids did you like that all these
movies are available on itunes or
netflix in some places
amazon and other places you can find
them they're available
patronize them if you will uh also if
you like this kind of stuff
come on over to that kevin smith club go
to thatkevinsmithclub.com
join up man i do wake and bake three
times a week where i wake up just smoke
weed with y'all and stuff come to that
kevin smith club for more
video antics with kevin smith